[Musique]
notre association a pour but objectif
pour défendre les personnes les droits
des personnes en situation d'handicap et
lutter contre l'isolement des personnes
en situation d'handicap l'insérer de la
société parce que nous disons que le
handicap il est physique Intels
psychologique à tous les niveaux donc il
faut que les personnes en situation
handicap physique visible soit bien
traité par la société et soit inséré
dans la société et reconnu comme tel
parce que nous sommes tous des êtres
humains à part entière
c'est d'abord effectivement sensibiliser
rencontrer les parents qui ont des
enfants en situation d'handicap voient
les difficultés et pouvoir les orienter
parce que nous avons
reçu des personnes des parents qui ont
des soucis de l'orienter leur enfant qui
en situation d'handicap donc nous nous
recherchons voilà les besoins et pour
les accompagner correctement pour leur
insertions de la vie sociale
le programme c'est le ballon déjà la
cérémonie démarre à 15h la réception des
invités et
15h15 la présentation le discours du
président la prestation du poète qui
sera là et après cette prestation il y
aura l'échange avec les parents pour
recueillir les besoins et avec aussi les
personnes en situation d'handicap pour
pouvoir réellement connaître savoir les
besoins pour que la handicace c'était
plus les accompagner auprès des
autorités compétentes
[Musique]